and we start with breaking news tonight
A man is dead after a shooting in the
West Valley police say it happened at a
home near Buffalo and Alto earlier
tonight that's where we find Sasha
Loftus live now joining us with the
latest as the investigation does
continue Sasha
Brian you can see behind me this scene
is still very active as police continue
this situation here this investigation
rather here near Buffalo and Alta in
this neighborhood now they say that this
happened just a few hours ago they got a
call around 6 45 this evening a woman
saying her boyfriend had shot another
man inside their home now when they
arrived on scene police found a man shot
and killed in the backyard the woman's
boyfriend was taken into custody police
tell us before this shooting the man who
was killed got into an argument with the
woman outside and beat several cars in
the driveway with a baseball bat then
kicked the door in to get into the home
right now this does appear to be an
isolated incident this is not a random
act of violence these two parties
obviously knew one another in my opinion
based on what I preliminarily know right
now there is no one outstanding as it
pertains this uh this incident
now police say it's too early in the
investigation to know whether any
charges will be filed here officers are
still looking for information as to
exactly what led up to this now back out
here live again this investigation
continues in this neighborhood here
should continue for a while longer if
you have any information please call
police or you can call Crime Stoppers to
remain anonymous reporting live tonight
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now